so dice was one of your mentors dice
clay the great Andrew Dice Clay who I
love and I know Andrew all these years
but when he was happenin big time I mean
there was no bigger comic this and he
took you under his wing yeah and at some
point he gave you a break he let you
open for him right and we are in Vegas
or something yeah at the Stardust hotel
so I'm like this is it I'm going to Las
Vegas with dice clay I'm gonna make it
I'm in it I make the beautiful Stardust
Hotel right we're probably gonna go out
to a lot of nightclub totally that's
what I would imagine so I didn't really
know dice I didn't know like but I just
knew like oh maybe you know like he's
got to go out right so we go there and
he goes we're going furniture show so we
went in and I go lay on that couch and I
got dice the things 8 grand it's it's
better than anything I got at home I'm
sure it's fine so yeah we would we would
go shopping for carpeting what a
disappointment I mean here you are in
Vegas you're a young guy did a party
you're ready to have fun and we're a
Twix